- Le tribunal de New York
a rendu public lundi
les détails d'un accord
de règlement signé il y a
13 ans entre Virginia Robert
et Jeffrey Epstein.
On apprend qu'à l'époque,
la jeune femme voulait
entamer des poursuites
judiciaires envers
le millionnaire, qu'elle
accusait de l'avoir exploitée
et agressée sexuellement
à plusieurs reprises
alors qu'elle était adolescente.
Mais cette poursuite
ne s'est jamais concrétisée.
Le 17 novembre 2009,
Jeffrey Epstein conclut
une entente avec la présumée
victime et lui offre
0 0 0 000 dollars.
Virginobobobert s'engage
alors à garder le silence,
et refuse toutes poursuites
judiciaires envers l'entourage
de Jeffrey Epstein.
Au mois d'août 2021,
Virginia Robert revient devant
les tribunaux et accuse
le prince Andrew de l'avoir
agressée sexuellement
à plusieurs reprises
au début des années 2000,
alors qu'elle avait 17 ans,
et sous l'emprise de Jeffr
Epstein, affirme-t-elle.Les audt
commencer mardi à New York.
La justice américaine
va examiner la validité
de la plainte.
Le prince Andrew rejette
catégoriquement les allégations.
Ses avocats affirment
que l'accord signé en 2009
le protège contre certaines
réclamations et constituera
un motif suffisant pour
le rejet de la poursuite.
Rappelons que Jeffrey Epstein
a été arrêté et accusé d'avoir
agressé sexuellement
des dizaines de jeunes filles
au début des années 2000.
Un mois plus tard, il est mort
dans sa cellule, sans avoir eu
à faire face à la justice.
Sa complice de l'époque,
Ghislaine Maxwell, a été
reconnue coupable de trafic
sexuel la semaine dernière
à New York.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, Montréa